all right I will be back with you soon -
right now he hosts CNN to lead with Jake
Tapper and State of the Union with Jake
Tapper guess who Jake Tapper look
everybody its Jake Tapper
okay so I'm sure people have told you
this before but you know you have the
best porn name ever
Jake okay so I'm glad you're familiar
with my role your work so you have a lot
of new fans which is great you deserve
it yeah you're doing a great job over
there of speaking truth - crazy that's
what takes to [ __ ] to power but then
this is a different job and tell us a
little bit about how you would say your
job has changed since Donald Trump
because president because you certainly
sound different than I ever saw you for
the many years I've watched you well
you've been covering politicians for a
long time politicians why it didn't yeah
it wasn't invented on January 20 yeah
you were just talking about how the
Democrats weren't forthright about
Obamacare we could go back to the Iraq
war and on and on
I've never really seen this level of
falsehood it's different
just quantitatively completely new
because it's not just if you like your
doctor you can keep your doctor it right
conspiracy theories and based on nothing
right that have members of his own party
distancing themselves from him as when
it's combined with an attempt to
discredit the entire Fourth Estate the
entire media we're all faking it was all
of us except for Fox and Friends you
take it personally I don't think of
personally I didn't like it the thing
that offended me the most personally was
when he went after John McCain for not
being a war hero that bothered me just
as somebody and then when Senator McCain
started asking questions about the Yemen
raid and the White House suggested that
how dare he anyone questioned the this
military mission Senator John McCain is
the chairman of the Senate Armed
Services Committee Sharon actually
literally his job to question a military
operation yeah so there's his effort to
undercut you know the Fourth Estate
legislative oversight the judicial
branch so-called judges so this
combination of falsehoods 3 to 5 million
illegal votes yes at Cruz's dad help
killed Kennedy yeah it's I think I mean
what they're laughing this I know it's
just the news I know it's just a news
these are the facts and on I watch you
and you do you know call it on like go
Jacob but then I but but then I realized
that with you yeah that was me it's a
it's it's a terrible conundrum urine
because you know the more you call it
out the more his fans say you're being
biased right you know the more they see
you do that they go oh well Trump's
right he's in the tank for the other
side times everything is so politicized
there is no truth for anybody left and
so the more you actually do your job
well the more you're not giving credit
by the people who you actually need to
convince but I refuse to buy into that
very I refuse to buy into that paradigm
because the truth of the matter is that
there's no bias when it comes to fact
and facts and there's no bias when it
comes to defenses
and well yeah I mean it is empirically
indecent to make fun of the disabled yes
you don't have to be a Democrat or a
Republican or an independent or whatever
socialist libertarian that's just
indecent yeah my children know better
than that yeah I know no I I always
think about that book everything I
needed to know I learned in kindergarten
now he violates every rule don't lie
don't accuse people with things are not
guilty of don't boast pay your taxes
serve your country don't be a racist
don't insult like you say the
handicapped people and other people who
are not as lucky to be as great-looking
as you are Donald I worry that if half
the country wants this guy to be
president we do need the UN to step in
or the United Federation of Planets or
something I don't know anyway here's the
thing I think a lot of people voted for
Trump not because of that stuff but
despite that stuff I think that they'll
oh yeah you're right because I don't
think they voted for him they heard the
Access Hollywood tape and they thought
oh yeah I want that in the White House
all right thank right I think that they
didn't like Hillary Clinton for a bunch
of reasons that I'm not going to cite
here because Barney Frank will come and
hit me and they wanted Washington to do
something for them it's not empirically
wrong to say Washington isn't working
for the American people and Washington
does too many things for powerful
special interests and the D you know
it's broken and some of it is what
Andrew was just talking about they just
like it when liberals are crying so
anybody whose sticks of thumb in
liberalism's I that's a good person
there's some of that in some of his
supporters I think that's true but he
was also sticking his thumb in the eyes
of Paul Ryan he was also sticking his I
mean believe me you know Jeb Bush is
like Oedipus at this point
oh yeah yeah that's true and mrs. Bush
that was not a reference no no just a
blind part but good so he was sticking
his fingers in the eyes of everybody
everybody in the establishment so do you
think that Cable News and CNN which
you're a part of is somewhat complicit
in putting him in the White House I mean
Cable News did cover him like he was
already the president before he was the
president and I would say that they went
made way too big a thing of Hillary's
emails the Clinton Foundation all this
[ __ ] I agree with what Barney that I
think that the media has made a good
turn but I do think I have to own that
path I think that there's certainly
first of all not be on budget for the
entire media but but I think that there
are certainly fair critiques of the
media when it comes to especially
running a lot of the Trump rallies early
on start to finish no editorial comments
just like what is this what are we doing
here and CNN did that Fox did it MSNBC
did it and my boss Jeff Zucker has
acknowledged that we did that too much
early on I think that some of the
toughest interviews that were done at
President Trump and Hillary Clinton for
that matter were on CNN I mean I know
you saw my interview turns out
coincidentally the last one I ever did
with him with when I press them on the
judge curio masher when I asked him
about the Ku Klux Klan and that's not
what I'm asking about it I however hard
they were on him they spent too much
time on her and her [ __ ] and those
issues were [ __ ] all right I want to
ask you one last thing which is about
the Correspondents Dinner
yeah Trump is not going you go where I
go it's a company dinner okay
so here are some things Trump has called
reporters dishonest discredited disaster
dwindling dummy dope crazy clown
neurotic mess boring biased no-talent
loser sloppy grubby grubby third-rate
sad fake tanking fraud pathetic phony
terrible negative one-sided
troublemakers crooked scum and of course
sad why aren't you going why aren't you
going donald ruck on he does have a way
with words i it's just a scandal that he
doesn't go no okay good i don't think it
doesn't bother me that he's not going
the truth of the matter is it's a great
dinner for the scholarship that it did
it right it pays for journalism students
it's a great dinner to recognize good
journalism i think that most of us in
washington probably feel a little
ambivalent about the whole idea of yes
musing with schmoozing people who you're
supposed to be yeah yeah and i think
well yeah i mean i don't think it's any
great effrontery to democracy that he's
not coming I think it's fine I'm sure
vice president Pence will fill the role
well keep holding their feet to the fire
thank you sir I realize watching thanks
I always